uh let's go next to alan from south
africa alan welcome
hey uh obligatory can you hear me i can
hear you fine
great um so my question is
what do you think
what issues do you think
joe biden can address and in what ways
to maybe save his presidency at this
point so student loan
forgiveness would be a big deal
uh see being seen as successfully
winding down russia's invasion of
ukraine not that it's his job to figure
it out but if he could credibly
negotiate an off-ramp for russia i think
that that would help him cannabis
decriminalization i think would probably
help him as well you know we have to be
realistic because we're now under six
months to these elections
and what can be done in that amount of
time i don't think there's any way in
hell that he gets immigration reform
done
i don't think he gets taxes done i don't
think he has health care so i'm just
thinking like what could realistically
happen and i think that some student
loan forgiveness could
somewhat of a solution in russia ukraine
maybe and if he was determined you know
maybe something on cannabis but i don't
i don't he doesn't seem super interested
in that
yeah i think i agree there um and the
other thing i wanted to ask was
would you consider covering more
international news i know you can't
cover everything it would be impossible
um but there's so much going on in the
world
like for example the i don't know if you
covered this actually the
uh the election in philippines it's a
lot of things that i know your audience
is quite international yeah
would you consider um
you know covering some of some
some topics that are that are going on
in the world i mean apart from obviously
the ukrainian russian uh conflict so we
did cover the philippines election
actually it was on the bonus show you
know the award-winning world famous
bonus show that alex jones doesn't like
uh we didn't cover it on the on the
broadcast show we uh i'm always willing
to do international stories it's just
they tend not to do well they they get
very little interest reaction engagement
reviews and at a certain point you know
we're not just picking stuff based on
views but if we do something and there
just seems to be very little interest it
does make me question whether it's the
right thing to be covering you know
right okay yeah that makes sense uh
great well thank you so much have a good
day thank you very much i appreciate it